voilà nous sommes de retour en direct
d'avoriaz l'occasion du festival du film
français et je crois qu'on a des
questions à olivier segond d'art oui je
vais décevoir catherine jacob vous n'en
voulez pas catherine parce qu'on va
aller à paris pour une question pour
jean rochefort
oh là là mais je suis désolé quatrième
plan d eau les questions 6 y en avait
mais à l'instant c'est jean rochefort à
l'instance et jean rochefort bonsoir
paris alo oui oui bonsoir oui pourquoi
vous appelez comment jean pierre jean
pierre et donc vous nous appelez de
quelques quartiers dans paris paris dans
18 cas vous avez quel âge et qu'est ce
que vous faites dans la ville
jean-pierre racontez nous un petit peu
j'ai 28 ans et je travaille dans la
publicité
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça va la
journée s'est bien passée vous avez une
question pour jean rochefort donc alors
mais vous aimez beaucoup ce que fait
catherine jacob aussi j'aime beaucoup
catherine jacob voilà très bien là oui
là c'est mieux des gens bien comme ça
alesi est d'ailleurs très content
d'ailleurs quelle phase retour que les
héros comique parce que elle m'a fait
beaucoup rire mais je suis sûr qu'elle
veut encore beaucoup nous surprendre
dans d'autres registres catherine 6 ou
pire comme c'est me jean-pierre votre
question je transporte alors visé
comtois bonsoir
j'aime recevoir depuis comporter des
moustaches avait déjà un jour rage est
gelée je les porte depuis depuis
longtemps de à l'âge de 40 ans il ya de
gros mal de temps j'ai joué le
misanthrope et je me suis aperçu que ma
fausse moustache partait tout le temps
alors j'ai décidé de laisser pousser la
mienne et j'ai gardé parce que lui quand
je l'enlève il m'est arrivé dans le vélo
trois fois j'ai l'impression de plus
avoir de slips monsieur voilà oui john
est très drôle
un espace énorme entre
c'est supérieur et je me trouve obscène
sans moustache
oui la barbe n'ont jamais aussi je suis
si j'ai dû la voir dans deux ou trois
films là bas si jean-pierre j'imagine
que vous êtes satisfait de ce genre de
réponse très bien bas merci pour votre
fidélité et à et à très bientôt
après la question de jean-pierre vous
pouvez continuer nous appeler pour
d'autres questions en attente